[Musica]
condivisione tutti in sala conosciamo
questa parola vero sì eppure forse alla
fine di questo intervento scopriremo la
sua vera importanza è il suo vero potere
oggigiorno il mondo è cambiato bianca è
in atto un cambiamento sociale molto
profondo il mondo non è più quello per
cui siamo stati educati
oggi ci sono persone che hanno delle uno
spirito nuovo
cercano esperienze nuove sono
completamente distinte da quelle che
esistevano anni ed anni fa mi faccio un
esempio
guardate qui oggi giorni ma ci sono
persone che non vogliono più fare la
classica vacanza con gli amici al male
che preferiscono fare esperienze diverse
aggiunge sport estremi avventure
appassionanti cercare posti dove poter
vivere esperienze uniche
ci sono persone ancora che visitano
prigioni borghi abbandonati altri luoghi
e completamente differenti si è passati
da voler visitare le città più
importanti al mondo
gli edifici emblematici a voler visitare
questo la favela della lo segna in
brasile per una mia foto o ancora volete
andare a fare volontariato in una scuola
in birmania o semplicemente volete
visitare una ebbene forse alcuni di voi
penseranno che io rappresento solo una
persona su 100 questa non è la prassi
generale e beh mi dispiace contraddirti
ma ci sono sempre più persone in questo
mondo che hanno delle aspirazioni che
non hanno nulla a che vedere con il
lusso di un hotel 5 stelle sua spiaggia
anzi oggigiorno chi pensa solo in
termini di lusso e il rimane distanza
dagli altri non è parte del gruppo non
empatizza con gli altri
perché il mondo è cambiato oggi c'è la
globalizzazione ci sono belle bari e
sempre più ridotte e quindi ci sono
sempre più importanti l'empatia alla
condivisione ed è sempre più mal vista
diciamo l'egoismo sempre più mal visto e
quindi in questo mondo è cambiato e
ancora siamo davanti a una nuova messa a
fuoco nel mondo la società a sfocato
autofocus la vetta
allora concettualmente nell'antica messa
a fuoco del mondo noi eravamo ciò che
avevamo i nostri averi i nostri beni
erano da rappresentazione del nostro
valore e del nostro successo
e invece oggi questo sta cambiando
vi faccio un esempio a cosa mi serve una
volta soddisfatte le esigenze
fondamentali comprare un altro computer
e quello che ciò mi fa benissimo come
funziona perfettamente
non ho bisogno di un altro computer
probabilmente anziché voler comprare
quest'altro computer una nuova proprietà
voglio spendere i miei soldi per
visitare una tribù di cacciatori
raccoglitori in tanzania e prenderle a
cercare che non è facile raggiungerli e
quando si va lì si scopre che questa
gente caccia con arco e frecce e da
foglie frutta questo vivo in questa
maniera però condividendo tutto
all'interno del loro clan ed uno sono
felici sono allegri sono solari spessa
ponente sono molto più felici di noi che
sulla carta abbiamo tutto qui in italia
giusto quindi autofocus
cerchiamo di vedere il mondo in
un'ottica completamente distinta e poi
facciamo un altro discorso cos'è la
condivisione se non l'antidoto alla
solitudine la solitudine tutti quanti
scappiamo dalla solitudine
fate ciclo guardate questa immagine e
pensate a quanto siamo tutti quanti
tutti i giorni la nostra vita
costantemente poi non sa cellulare in
mano con i nostri amici virtuali e
portateli laiche di click
eppure abbiamo sempre bisogno di avere
persona nel suo fianco è una ricerca
dell'altro e ci accomuna tutti anziani e
bambini giovani adulti tutti vi faccio
un esempio guardiamo ancora oggi giorno
ci sono persone che in questa ricerca e
l'altro
ci sono non vi faccio un esempio che
iniziano inviare gli stickers di
whatsapp o si relazionano in una maniera
completamente diversa
queste mia suocera con il tatuaggio si
si tatuano 60 anni e ancora 60 anni
fanno dell'esperienza è completamente
nuove vanno in viaggio in moto per la
prima volta la loro vita e lo fanno per
fare una nuova esperienza per non
sentirsi sole ed essere parte di questo
mondo condividere con gli altri anche
con i più giovani quindi per sempre più
membri della nostra società questa parte
di condivisione sociale è molto molto
molto molto importante
e ancora questa voglia di scappare dalla
solitudine accomuna come avevo detto
prima giovani e adulti anche i giovani
hanno paura di questa solitudine tutti
quanti scappiamo la solitudine i giovani
vivono in un nuovo mondo nel quale tutto
intorno a loro è cambiato il modo di
vivere è cambiato oggigiorno questi
giovani cercano sempre meno la
solitudine è sempre più la condivisione
e vivere in comunità
il fenomeno erasmus per esempio è solo
la punta dell'iceberg
se ci fate caso oggigiorno la gente
vuole andare un è dipendenza si ai
propri genitori però decide di andare a
vivere un appartamento condiviso e non è
solo una questione economica è anche una
questione di scelta di vita è una scelta
di vita e non solo è cambiato il modo di
vivere cambiato scusate è cambiato anche
il modo di lavorare
vi ricordate le grandi scrivanie quando
la rappresentazione del nostro successo
professionale era data da una grande
scrivania dall ufficio privato oggi
anche questo è completamente scomparso
quante aziende organizzano i
brainstorming o le riunioni di aziendale
in una baita in montagna o comunque in
qualunque altro posto lontano decine di
chilometri all ufficio
questo perché c'è un altro cambio in
atto e il cambio è già arrivato e già
presente già qui quindi cerchiamo di
interiorizzarlo oggigiorno non si vuole
più lavorare in un ufficio si preferisce
un working che è questo se riusciamo
ecco questo è un working che succede si
condividono degli spazi ma si
condividono anche dei progetti ed è
bello avere persone alto lato che la
pensano come te
dal più stare con un vicino ad altra
gente dà allegria e gioia di vivere
se ci pensate finora non vi ho detto
nulla di completamente nuovo vero più o
meno vi suona tutto quello che vi sto
raccontando
perché il cambio è già qui
la prospettiva è cambiata quindi il
mondo va visto e analizzando guardandolo
con dagli occhi differenti quindi
cerchiamo di interiorizzarlo dentro noi
stessi e di riprogrammarsi si è parlato
molto finora di fenomeni come il
coworking all appartamento condiviso ma
io sono venuto qui per dirvi che questo
è il passato e il prossimo futuro è una
fusione di questi due fenomeni e molto
altro ancora
charles darwin diceva che lui diceva che
praticamente evoluzione colui che si
adatta al cambiamento
ebbene il cambiamento e la condivisione
quindi cerchiamo di adattarci a questo
cambiamento e lo faccio da sempre
e sinceramente non è poi così difficile
se volete vi racconto un po di storia
della mia vita io ho vissuto in vari
paesi
parla diverse lingue vi sole azionato
con vari culture ho condiviso mi sono
confrontato e quando sono arrivato in
spagna gennaio 2009 a madrid ho studiato
un master al termine del quale ho deciso
di lanciare un azienda avrebbe aiutato i
giovani come me cosa fece scattare la
miccia no è praticamente ci fu meno reso
conto del cambio intorno a me il cambio
nel modo di vedere e di osservare il
mondo e dieci anni fa il mondo diventava
sempre più globale sempre più flessibile
così mi mise all'opera i primi passi nel
mondo imprenditoriale rimossi lanciando
una carta una società di housing in
appartamento condiviso in pratica come
dire offrivo stanze ammobiliate ben
fatte in appartamenti condivisi dove
c'era una zona comune per poter
socializzare con gli altri e la offrivo
anche la risoluzione dei problemi che
comportano un cambio di residenza
ebbene durante gli ultimi dieci anni la
nostra azienda ha aiutato oltre 15 mila
persone in italia e in spagna a poter
vivere la sua nuova esperienza di lavoro
di studio di erasmus ma fondamentalmente
di vita quindi poter vivere appieno la
propria vita
è inoltre in tutti questi anni abbiamo
continuato a guardare il mondo cambiare
intorno a noi vi facciamo un altro
esempio
scusate questo ragazzo che vivete e si
chiama roll del francese è un
collaboratore e amico lui ha iniziato a
lavorare con noi
nove anni fa e in breve tempo divenne
anche il direttore della compagnia è una
persona brillante e lui era felice
ovviamente nella sua posizione si
sentiva realizzato sentiva bene eppure
un giorno decide di abbandonare tutto
zaino in spalla se ne va a viaggiare in
africa senza viaggio organizzato senza
nulla programmato completamente
all'avventura giustamente lo guardiamo
di siamo una roma così pazzo che è
successo e lui ci dice testualmente
ragazzi avete ragione ma io ho bisogno
di percepire percepire il mondo aveva
bisogno di percepire il mondo conoscere
altre culture relazionarsi con una
persone capire ciò che piaceva loro ciò
che le spaventa e questa necessità di
incontrare l'altro è qualcosa che non è
solo di harold e di tanta gente se per
sempre più persone condividere
importante e molte persone si sentono
felici solo ed esclusivamente quando
condividono la loro vita vi faccio un
altro esempio oltre harold anche altre
persone hanno sperimentato questo otto
anni fa viene a vivere da noi un ragazzo
carlos tra l'altro una persona ricca di
molto buona famiglia direttore marketing
di una multinazionale e lui
precedentemente viveva in un attico con
piscina privata eppure non si sentiva
felice quindi ci contatta che ci dice io
non mi sento solo
ho bisogno di un ambiente internazionale
di confrontarmi con altre culture e ci
premuta la star appartamento una stanza
dell'appartamento più grande che avevamo
da otto stanze quindi immaginiamo che
cambio e da una un attico con piscina
privata un appartamento condiviso
e una persona che non ha problemi
economici perché questa persona come
molte persone che condivide un
appartamento non cerca solo un risparmio
e cerca qualcosa di completamente
diverso differente cerca nuove culture
nuove lingue nuove emozioni o esperienze
e la nostra società giustamente si è
resa conto di questo cambio e quindi
dopo aver lanciato appartamento
condiviso o il coworking poi siamo
passati a relazionarci con altre società
associarci per poter offrire nuovi
servizi e quindi viaggi escursioni
piuttosto facciamo prima lo faccio
vedere questo è un esempio di ciò che
offriamo tutte le settimane quindi dal
dal bowling la domenica alla danza
all'inter cambio di lingua
fondamentalmente la nostra società è
passata dalla stanza al con working
all'esperienza e quindi è l'emozione
e lo so la nostra intenzione nel
prossimo futuro e miscelare tutte queste
cose in un unico grande spazio perché
nella nostra visione lo spazio cambia di
dimensione la mia riforma va visto in
una maniera distinta vi faccio un
esempio se io sono un freelance no
cosa c'è di meglio per me che vivere a
fianco a fianco con la gente che come me
conoscerli approfittarmi delle loro
capacità per lanciare progetti insieme
vincenti ovviamente quindi posso fare
tutto nello stesso posto ben venga
proprio l'ideale quindi lo chiediamo che
il futuro sia il co living il co living
ovviamente ci sono tanti tipi di co
living il collini e un modello che si
adatta a tanti tipi di personali
distinte età professioni esperienze modi
di pensare quindi tutta questi modelli
distinti di cui living stuff e hanno la
stessa honda che quella della felicità
che si prova nel condividere la propria
vita con gli altri
la felicità
e quindi ovviamente ora vi parlerò del
quelli lingue bano per giovani però
questo può essere adattato in qualunque
contesto in qualunque realtà veranda
mediana o piccola va bene a madrid
e va bene ha tranquillamente a cosenza
va bene ovunque e quelli l'ing non è
altro che è la datazione al mercato
della casa del concetto di coworking
quindi diciamo si dotano di spazi ai
giovani residenti nel nostro caso
giovani e questi residenti possono
condividere lavoro che la vita è
ovviamente per permettere l'interazione
tra queste persone vi sono una serie di
spazi comuni quali palestra e sale da
pranzo sala giochi per poter interagire
home cinema eccetera eccetera
e ancora si possono offrire lezioni di
yoga organizzare eventi regolarmente ma
il concetto che tutto è progettato e
costruito per favorire questa
interazione
tra i co livers quindi stiamo parlando
di permettere un'integrazione tanto del
lavoro coworking come la vita con living
e creare forti sinergie tra i loro
progetti
e poi ancora abbiamo dei community
managers che veicolano le attività di co
livers ancora abbiamo un cinema abbiamo
la un'applicazione per esempio nel con
la quale si può prenotare il cibo alla
reception o ancora si può vedere chi è
nello stabilimento stabilimento
nell'edificio e poi preciso istante per
comunicare con lui per qualunque tipo di
problematica o di progetto privato o
lavorativo e ancora si può fare
qualsiasi cosa si può prenotare una
stanza per un evento privato quindi
concettualmente il co living è un
modello di business adattato alla nuova
realtà che quella della condivisione
della vita
quindi nel nostro caso questo nel nostro
caso questo progetto che stiamo
lanciando a valentia è un progetto real
180 stanze però la cosa che realmente
importa è che come potete vedere ci sono
praticamente tante zone comuni e quindi
zone comuni per poter studiare per poter
fare sport per poter lavorare ovviamente
ma non è un avere una stanza e
condividere le zone comuni è un concetto
che la molto più in là è un concetto di
comunità quindi i nostri clienti non
solo condividono gli spazi dell'immobile
condividono anche le mozioni
l'esperienza e lo sport
gli hobby condividono tutta la loro vita
ovviamente se iniziate a fare tante cose
durante il giorno siete circondati da
persone affini a voi iniziato a fare
molte più cose uscite insieme la sera
iniziate andare a fare sport insieme
quindi alla fine si ha una vita molto
più piena
molto più felice questo il concetto del
co living e quindi
quello che io voglio come imprenditore
già non è solo creare un business anche
ma non è solo qualche concetto il
concetto è quello di far vivere delle
emozioni delle esperienze e fa vivere
per queste persone insieme nello sport
nel lavoro nello studio e fare in modo
che portino nel loro cuore per le storia
loro vita questi grandissimi ricordi la
nostra società vuole rapportarsi a
questo nuovo mondo che si sta creando
che quello della condivisione appunto
tramite il call healing che questo
modello che permette la condivisione
della vita
quindi si passa dall coli vino a quello
che io definisco il life sharing cioè la
condivisione della vita e quindi
concettualmente per concludere si è
molto più felici e se vi è molto meglio
quando si decide di condividere tutto
cibo feste emozioni e si smettesse di
soli quando si condivide
vi ricordate di harold no del mio amico
bene
rendiamoci conto che dalle grandi
esperienze nascono relazioni che vanno
avanti tutta la vita quindi dopo nove
anni dal nostro primo incontro
noi continuiamo a collaborare malgrado
le distanze dal messico e siamo uniti da
una forte amicizia io sono
orgogliosissimo di essere stato scelto
come il suo testimone di nozze e il suo
matrimonio a novembre
perché la condivisione non conosce
nessun tipo di barriera grazie
[Applauso]